Nene comes up shot clock at nine outside
Novell glances at the clock 2010
audacity get to the bottom and we'll
take a two-point lead at halftime and
this with Texas Tech switching OD hace
is on Norville he falls down and that
opens it up inside deadly three-point
shooters for producing Eastern from
there
shot clock down to four five he
here this guy
Klein the unorthodox shot look at the
hitch
look at the [ __ ] back never shoot the
gap on the shooter when you have two
screens coming he gave back to three he
just knocked that head where it's a low
ridge
[Applause]
nothing but net Edwards first-team
all-big ten to Rome sure mapped out the
Akita
the park got a chance to live in here
[Music]
dear Kinte
dat take these gents the town he floated
up over the outstretched arms of home
this is what you have to love this is
what the tournament is about
splits it drama piled into a scars wanna
[ __ ] buy tied to Rome go but on the
other hand Rome get him anywhere he
wants to for the flip shot track
desperately when he gets it open lot of
heroes a very good defensive player
Brown let's add one bottom a three here
you go I mean he's gonna mind his open
shots or the line when you have a shot
like that even a big guy gets hit the
eye Dunbar couldn't control it save by
Washington to a long one Hagen's playing
cash flips it up no a touch out of
control but what an effort from behind
that didn't get to the glass by the way
so that's a good block then you take a
look at it big split second the more
trying to hold his ground with Travis
quickly lines it up air ball goodbye
Washington Travis's their tough bucket
on the inside with a shot clock winding
down
up ahead quickly don't get back
[Applause]
is that impressive standing still and
though post up here he comes
[Applause]
took off the pits here senior and that
explosive boom rim Jim that wasn't a
first step that was a first blur right
there just went joins and got bumped a
little bit as well I think a wet stick
big plays there bacon McQuaid loves the
shot on the wing makes it
[Applause]
no less for that is unbelievable
hor as Ian you're out
that's know where you are from Texas
though the Tuesday for Williamson look
at it officially thought somos on
and as he should look at this little
deaf Mouse bass head bring it at all
fourth foul on DeLaurier whoa we gotta
see you now we got an ex said that in he
said it best over the past